hello I'm Greg Sadler and I would like
to tell you about a great new online
class that I have coming up that you
might want to check out and possibly
enroll in so it's titled ancient
philosophers on friendship and it is a
10-week online synchronous class in the
study with Sadler a Academy now
synchronous means that we will be
meeting once a week for 90-minute class
sessions on Thursdays at 10:00 a.m.
Central Time so you might want to check
your time zone to see whether that will
fit your schedule we will be recording
all of the class sessions as resources
for the students that they get lifetime
access to you have the opportunity to
not only hear me talk about the texts
and thinkers that we're going to be
reading but to interact with me directly
in the class sessions and so why
philosophers on friendship well it's a
really important topic not only for us
in the present but in the ancient world
they felt this to be really Central to
making people happy to having good lives
and there were all sorts of problems
questions conundrums paradoxes that
arise Within the framework of these
intense personal relationships so we are
going to be looking at a representative
spectrum of ideas from platonists
aristotelians stoics eclectics epicurian
and others from the ancient period let
me run you through what the planned
curriculum is for each week so in the
first week we're going to start out with
Plato's dialogue the the lissus which is
about friendship and goes through a lot
of models and problems with friendship
we're also going to look briefly at
Republic book one and the notion of
doing good to your friends and bad to
your enemies then in weeks two and three
we're going to be looking at when when
we talk about philosophers on friendship
who comes to mind Aristotle nickan
ethics books 8 and N but we're also
going to be looking at the Udan ethics
and we'll tie it in with some other
material that comes up within the
nicoman ethics earlier in it and perhaps
even in some of his other works in week
four we're going to be looking at the
epicurian tradition starting with
epicurus himself we'll delve into
lucretius as well and we'll even get our
first taste of Cicero with on the ends
book one in which the main character
torquatus is is an epicurian and is
presenting their point of view on
friendship and many other matters in
week five we're going to look at a
dialogue that is explicitly about
friendship cisero classic de amaka or on
friendship raising all sorts of
interesting problems not only from the
Greeks and Roman society but things that
apply to us in the present in week six
we're going to turn directly to the
stoics and we're going to look at a
number of senica's letters that deal
with the topic of friendship in week
seven we're going to come back to the
platonist tradition with the great
middle platonist Plutarch who has two
very interesting works that we're going
to look at how to tell a flatterer from
a friend and on having many friends in
week eight we're going to get our first
taste of the cynic with Dio system and
some of his discourses week nine we come
back to the stoics with epicus looking
at passages within his discourses and
the enidan that are gerine to friendship
and other personal relationships and we
will finish up by looking at an author
and you might say oh this guy's not a
philosopher we're looking at Lucian of
Samosa who is yes a satirist and
dialogue writer but those tend to be
about philosophy so we'll be looking at
two of his pieces the toxaris or on
friendship and the parasite where he
argues that parasitism sponging off of
other people is indeed an art and this
ties in with plutarch's flatterer friend
thing so you see we get a great wide net
that we're casting and hopefully we'll
catch a lot of great idea fish within it
that then you can start applying within
your own life so all the important
information you can find Below in the
video description there's also a link to
where you can find out more about the
class check out a few of the previews
and sign up if you want to there are
going to be a limited number of spots
because we don't want to have you know
everybody and their brother proverbially
in the class you know we want to keep it
nice and close and friendly this study
of friendship but I hope that you'll
consider joining me for this 10 week
online class that you might actually
really enjoy perhaps even form some
friendships within and we're going to be
looking at these great ancient
philosophers and what they can tell us
about all of these
topics